hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 16 video deep dive
into the history of the League of
Assassins in the lineage of racial goal
because there were a couple really big
WTF reveals I'm just gonna start with
that first start with a couple
explainers so careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet so
starting with the Lazarus Pit this is
really the biggest surprise of the
episode mostly because they've been
telling us all along that fantastical
things like this didn't really exist in
the arrowverse or the flare averse
however you want to think about it since
we know it exists now when we start to
talk about more powers other characters
with superpowers on arrow we should just
you know think of it in terms of you
know arrow hasn't done it yet but that
doesn't mean it won't ever do it so even
if they say like time-travel
superman/batman crazy stuff isn't
happening on arrow it just means it's
not happening right now doesn't mean it
won't ever happen I think Stephen Amell
said in an interview before the season
started when people were asking him if
Rochelle Goyle was gonna come on in
season 3 he was like I think arrow has
proven as a show that all the things
that people want we will do eventually
we'll get to it eventually just to get
you guys even more excited for season 4
crazy stuff on arrow Stephen Amell said
the thing that he's most excited to show
people is the comic-con trailer this
summer that would be like season 4 stuff
so I think it implies that magic is
coming into the arrowverse the Lazarus
Pit is like the backdoor to magic there
was also some interview quotes where
they were talking about the Vixen
cartoon the digital cartoon her powers
are based on magic so there's gonna be
some interaction between the TV show the
live-action TV show and the cartoon not
direct crossover but it's just like
magic will exist in the arrowverse after
the way they're actually explaining the
lazarus pit in the arrowverse its
effects you know only work for a certain
amount of time it's not infinitely
renewable they kind of got into that on
the Batman cartoon demons quest where
Rachel Ghul tries to blackmail Batman
into becoming the next Rachel or taking
over the League of Assassins there was
also run in the comics where Batman goes
all over the world trying to destroy all
the Lazarus pits with Bane no less so
what we should all think about is that
there's gonna be any lazarus pit twists
aside from characters getting dumped in
and resurrected i think when you talk
about Lazarus pits resurrection is just
a given so usually when there's a twist
it's when someone is like super-dead and
then they come back
and I don't think that caity lotz I
think caity lotz is gonna be playing a
different character on the spin-off show
so just moving into top 5 moments lots
of awesome stuff in this episode
starting with number 5 the history of
the League of Assassins the comics take
a slightly different approach racial
goal was seen as just being much much
older than he is on the show but it's
the same idea he finds the Lazarus Pit
they've existed for a long time so he is
not like the first person in the history
of the world to ever use a Lazarus Pit
but I did like is that he teased Oliver
that he can change the league's mission
in their operating orders the league
serves racial goal in whatever he wants
to do so if Oliver tells him to stop
killing people they'll stop killing
people if he wants to completely change
their mission and use them to clean up
Starling city that's what they'll do
they really want us to see the Oliver's
stressing about this and it's not over
at all like Oliver might relent based on
what happened at the end Merlyn was not
lying when he said that the offer ratio
mate is not an offer and he does not
accept there's gonna be direct
consequences that was with that crazy
moment at the end of the episode was
about Rachel Gould dressing up as the
arrow to get people in the city thinking
that the arrow was a murderer there was
a scene in the trailer from a future
episode where Oliver's unmasking someone
in his costume so it looks like Rachel
was gonna have a bunch of people from
the League of Assassins dressing up as
the arrow walking around killing people
this is a nice twist on what Merlyn was
doing with Thea like trying to bring her
closer by doing something really
terrible moving on to number 4 Nyssa
is super pissed that Oliver is the new
heir she has a really nice friendship
that's developing with Laurel I'll be
related to see where that goes it seems
fairly positive so she might work with
team arrow to try and stop Rachel Ghul
from destroying the arrows reputation in
Starling city she wants to be the heir
Oliver wants out of the deal so it's
like the enemy of my enemy is my friend
and right now their collective enemy is
ratio cool I am such a huge fan of
Katrina on the show so any plot that
allows her to be in more scenes I am all
for I was a little surprised at how
casually she'd dismissed Thea's
confession I think she come around a
little bit by the end of the episode but
I still think she's skeptical she still
blames Merlyn for everything and as she
should it really is Merlin's fault
because of Fiat Nyssa now there's such
an awesome through line about awful dads
and you know Quentin and laurels
relationship is also on the rocks it's
very rocky but it's not quite as bad as
Gulen this artheon Merlin so I'm not
lumping Quentin in with the two other
awful dad's speaking of which answer
number three Quentin is now on the outs
with team arrow
despite that hopeful ending I think
given the WTF ratio will reveal Quentin
is gonna do a 180 again and he's gonna
start going after the arrow someone
meeting your description has been going
around killing people with arrows as
good of a detective as Quentin is I
think he's still looking for a reason to
hate the arrow so he's just gonna latch
on to that that being said you guys can
let me know if you agree or not but
Quentin knew that his daughter Sarah was
an assassin she killed people for a
living she lived by the sword so don't
you think that he would be emotionally
prepared or at least a little bit
prepared for her to die by the sword
it's understandable he's pissed Sarah's
dead and everyone lied to him about it
it's kind of like Thea situation she's
pissed everyone lied to her too but it's
not Oliver's fault that she joined the
League of Assassins she made that choice
herself it's all about the choices in
the consequences of those choices Marc
Guggenheim said that they would be
exploring you know quote unquote
consequences of terrible decisions in
the back half of the season I think
that's what's gonna wind up with someone
leaving the show someone getting killed
off we still don't have any confirmation
about who that's gonna be
but I did like the idea that thean Roy
or getting close again because Thea is
kind of like the Beth Green of arrow
anybody who starts to go out with her
ends up getting killed off the show
first there's Tommy they had a little
thing for a little bit even though Tommy
wasn't totally into it he's dead there
was the guy from the League of Assassins
who was masquerading as the DJ he died
now we have Colton so I think we should
put Colton on the watch list just be
careful although he was on the set there
was a picture of him on a set recently
but that could be smokescreen on to
number two this is a little bit more of
a fun one
so Felicity kind of rejoins team arrow
like she's kind of back on the team she
and Oliver are on good terms
I like how she implied that he would
become the most handsome demons head
ever there was a lot of body contact and
stuff so you know any of you are like
huge olicity fans
yes that's still simmering below the
surface Ray Palmer is gonna go off on
the spin-off show after season 3 so the
landing strip will be cleared for Oliver
and Felicity once again at least by the
end of the season really the funny thing
is is that like the awkward moment where
Oliver came in and Felicity and Ray were
flirting when he greeted ray he was
using his arrow voice like it lowered a
couple octaves just as much as Oliver
does not approve of Felicity with Ray
Felicity does not approve of evil
incorperated moments like that when they
don't do them too often or really funny
like yeah you have the big WTF action
scenes like in the police station but
then you have these really personal
character moments and finally my number
one WTF moment
Rachel Ghul is going to blackmail Oliver
into taking over the League of Assassins
based on the progression of the trailer
footage that we've seen it seems like
this will crescendo with someone dying
it's just like last year with the
mirakuru plot Roy ended up killing that
cop almost ended up killing a bunch of
his friends too that was around episode
19 20 then Moira died so hits the
fan then someone dies I think it's gonna
follow the same pattern this season what
raesha al Ghul is doing right now like
his plan to blackmail
Oliver is very similar to some Batman
story so I'll be interested to see you
know after it's all said and done which
characters they mix and match like who
is the Robin of the group who's the one
that rachel gould threatens to kill and
who's the one that ends up in the
lazarus pit at the end of the season
that's a good question so let me know in
the comments who do you think is going
to die this season and who do you think
is going to end up in the Lazarus Pit
I'll say right now my money on person
ending up in the lazarus pit is ratio
himself i think i think they're gonna
wind up killing him at the end and then
someone's gonna dump his body in the pit
no matter what fantastical stuff that
they're allowed to do there's no way
arrow as a show is going to fridge the
ratio Google character at the end of the
season he will walk or crawl away
somehow we do know he's not gonna be the
big villain of season 4 I believe that
we're gonna start getting teases for who
that person is in episodes 20 through 23
maybe not so the actual finale right now
damian darhk-- is the best theory
because it's rumoured to be a villain
that fits more with Felicity's skill set
just so she's more of an asset to the
team and fighting the big bat as for
right now she's not much help against
race goal so a couple really awesome
things to look forward to in next week's
episode so we are going to have the
Diggle Lyla wedding and it's a Suicide
Squad episode so be sure to subscribe to
get my video I'm really wondering how
much they're gonna reference Green Arrow
and black Canary's wedding from the
comics and for those that are asking I
am doing a QA for the flash and arrow
this week I'll post that tomorrow I'm
finishing my agents of shield video
right now so that'll actually be the
next video but then after that I'll post
my Q&A video I know there was a lot of
confusion about this episode of the
flash episode 16 next week's episode is
going to be a lot
part two of episode 15 he went back in
time so he's gonna be like reliving all
those events again just in case you guys
haven't seen it yet you can click here
from that flash video from last night
and you can click here for my top 5
ratio cool stories thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow now
let's all do the thing
you